there were sharp exchanges as the
candidates debated health care criminal
justice race relations and more former
Vice President Joe Biden came out
strongly attacking his rivals plans for
government-run universal health care
nobody's yet said how much it's gonna
cost
Biden clashed with senator Bernie
Sanders for a socialist you got a lot
more confidence in corporate America
than I do let us be clear Joe in the
United States of America we are spending
twice as much per capita on health care
as the Canadians or any other major
country on earth former cabinet
secretary who Leon Castro produced gasps
from the audience when he seemed to
question the 76 year old Biden's memory
by in if the qualifier are you
forgetting what you said of Maddox and
being for him you said just two minutes
ago amid the bickering senator Cory
Booker appealed for unity we've got one
shot to make Donald Trump a one-term
president and we cannot lose it by the
way we talk about each other or demonize
and degrade each other we can walk and
chew gum at the same time the candidates
were united in denouncing President
Trump for inflaming racial tensions that
we have a white supremacist in the White
House and he poses a mortal threat to
people of color all across this country
climate change was another area of
general agreement with candidates
promising to rejoin the Paris climate
agreement the existential crisis of our
time it's you know that movie the day
after tomorrow
it's today we have seen a warming in our
world like never before we're seeing
flooding in the Midwest flooding in
Houston fires in the West the candidates
also discussed a slew of gun control
measures former congressman beta or
Roarke whose hometown of El Paso is
still grieving following a mass shooting
last month was cheered loudly for a vow
to ban assault rifles hell yes we're
gonna take your ar-15 your ak-47
senator Kamala Harris said Trump for
some responsibility for the El Paso
shooting he pulled the trigger but he's
certainly been tweeting out the
ammunition foreign policy got very
little attention in the debate Sanders
had a smack down on Trump's China trade
war Trump thinks that trade policy is a
tweet at 3 o'clock in the morning there
did not seem to be any standout winners
or losers senator Cory Booker may have
revived his flagging campaign with an
eloquent performance Biden seemed more
energetic than he had in past debates
although he did seem to ramble at times
Sanders repeated well-worn themes of
democratic socialism while Warren seemed
to disappear from sight for long
stretches of time during the debate the
next democratic debate will be held on
the 15th of October in Ohio Rob Reynolds
al Jazeera Houston